el cociente de dos polinomios de x ivd x
puede escribirse en la forma de x entre
b x es igual a q de x + rx / vdx donde q
de xrx son polinomios y el grado de rd x
es menor que el grado de vd x escribe el
cociente 7x a la sexta más x al cubo más
de 2 x + 1 todo eso dividido entre x al
cuadrado en esta forma ok ahora en este
caso la tenemos muy fácil porque x al
cuadrado es un bono mío así que
realmente puedo ver esto como 7 x a
lasexta / x al cuadrado más x al cubo
entre x al cuadrado más 2 x / x al
cuadrado más 1 / x al cuadrado así que
comencemos 7x a lasexta / x al cuadrado
cuanto es eso pues el 7 baja y tengo x a
la sexta entre x al cuadrado que es x a
la cuarta
+ x al cubo entre x al cuadrado eso
sencillamente es x ahora recuerden que
herede x es un polinomio que tiene grado
menor que el grado de mpx b de x en este
caso es x al cuadrado por lo tanto
podría simplemente escribir el siguiente
término como más 2 x / x al cuadrado el
grado de 2x es 1 y el grado de x al
cuadrado es 2 por lo tanto podría
escribirlo así y luego + 1 / x al
cuadrado y esto sería correcto pero no
es exactamente la manera en la que
quieren que lo escribamos tenemos q de x
que es esta primera parte 7 x a la
cuarta más x y luego debería tener un
solo polinomio dividido entre x al
cuadrado que sería b de x en este caso
por lo tanto voy a poner esto con
denominador común y escribirlo como 2x
2 x + 1 noten que el paréntesis es
importante porque de otro modo esto no
estaría estaría dividiendo correctamente
ok entonces esa sería mi respuesta y qué
fue lo que pasó pues esencialmente lo
que hice fue dividir toda la parte del
polinomio que tenía grado mayor que el
grado de x al cuadrado que es 2 estos
dos términos y después cuando llegue a
un punto en el que los términos tenían
grado menor que x al cuadrado
simplemente lo dejé como esta 2 x 1
entre x al cuadrado sea lo que sea eso
si queremos la respuesta estamos en lo
correcto